luca was ist das für eine folge
mein name ist luca und ich zeig euch
gerne was für command ich und auch und
wenn er es allerdings mit dem ersten
command los geht möchte ich noch ganz
kurz 2 sah 33 sachen ich meine ich sage
euch eben drei noch drei wörter wird
ganz schnell erste sache ich habe keinen
shader drin weil ich das noch nicht
richtig installiert habe weil ich meinen
pc neu gemacht haben
8.1 alles läuft gut das war erst der
sache zweite sache ich will in den
nächsten folgen die serie bisschen
wieder so machen wie damals also mehr
zur kleinere commands die simple sachen
hinzufügen anstatt so riesige dinger die
dann so 1000 später als einzuführen also
echte sachen sowie das ganz am anfang
war und die dritte sache wenn ihr das
video seht bin ich wahrscheinlich gerade
am vorproduzieren das heißt es könnte
sein dass wir jetzt gerade command city
vor zwei wochen vielleicht raus gekommen
sind ich habe versucht extra zum
zeitpunkt der aufnahme gerade also
wahrscheinlich zwei wochen vorher die
coolsten commands rauszusuchen oder die
aktuellsten dies gab und ich hoffe das
habe ich ihn gekriegt aber ich bin hart
im modern zeigt die aktualität ist nicht
komplett gegeben aber jetzt fange ich an
mit nummer eins wir gehen erst mal ein /
gfp command unterstrichen block um einen
kommentar zu erreichen
das ist der wichtigste an dieser serie
ist natürlich der command blog wir
setzen hier mit einem hebel daneben
fügen dem command ein und drücken den
hebel und zwar dieser command von des
brockens basis der rainbow armor command
wir sehen schon das steht in der mitte
ein loading text ding und jetzt fällt
hier jeden moment ein oder andere
command blöcke runter genau der fallen
darunter
und wir gehen jedem moment im chat
eingeblendet jahr das motto wir können
jetzt hier auf activate klicken click to
activate dann passiert einfach gerade
nichts natürlich weiß nicht wieso das
nicht funktioniert wir klicken einfach
wieder auf da funktioniert gar nix ich
kann ich noch die treuen klicken ein
attest welt von das geklappt so ich
teste dass man gerade hier unten nochmal
und wir sehen schon wenn jedem moment
das kommando brötchen dort oben
erreichte fallen in die blöcke runter
und wir sehen jetzt im chat des morgens
tot und wenn wir jetzt auf activate
klicken jetzt klappt es und zwar die
remove the rainbow am mo 8 das war weil
ich die schuhe anhatte hat vorhin doch
geklappt also wenn ich jetzt drauf
clique da so
die kripo aber ja genau jetzt hat es
nicht geklappt und zwar seht ihr jetzt
schon ich habe einfach rainbow aber ein
ganz simpler command und zwar einfach
leder rüstung instant leder rüstung die
so dumm beleuchtet und so rum wimmelt
und so weiter und so fort und ihr könnt
ihr euch nicht wegnehmen wenn ihr team
getroffen dann vermehrt die sich nur
noch als sie beide die man an sondern
ihr müsst wirklich hier dann einfach
darauf klicken dann seid ihr wieder los
also das ist ganz simpel die rainbow
aber dann hat es doch dort wo fische und
geklappt ich hatte das nicht realisiert
immer weiter mit k2 dann kann dich dass
bernburg für den kompletten der zweite
command ist vom lob nahm und zwar wieder
ein sehr sehr kurzer komm mal und zwar
70 ein command blog hinflüge dort den
command einsätze den schalter um und wir
den schon wegen dieser block dort oben
erreicht geehrt haben wir eine
klitzekleine maschine disco blogs beim
aufnehmen wird da schon eingeblendet und
zwar dass damit aktiviert und wenn wir
jetzt eine fläche machen mit so ein paar
sealand törns beispielsweise ich das mal
hier noch ein paar hin hier hier hier
wenn ich mich jetzt hier drauf stelle
das wird nichts ich weiß nicht ist das
heute eventuell die folge wo ich alles
doppelt und dreifach eingeben muss also
ich mach es nochmal wir setzen das
dorthin der block oben wird erreicht
dass es komisch ist auch der test welt
hat alles geklappt disco blogs bei
laupheim hier sind die sachen alles
mögliche ich setze jetzt eine fläche von
zielländern stelle mich darauf jetzt
klappt es wieder wie komisch ist das
denn ja das ist das was der command
macht er macht das bei euch ihr seid
total epilepsie versiert und könnt euch
überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen cola co
machen
der norden er meinte dass er derzeit ein
bisschen stress hat und deswegen nicht
so viel co mannschaft deswegen hat er so
ein leichtes ding gemacht bei ihm
funktioniert da hier ist es nur so ein
bisschen erinnern mich so ein bisschen
an diesen virus command wo nach und nach
minecraft abgeschmiert ist ist hier zwar
nicht so dass es ab spielt aber es ist
sehr viele bekommen immer weiter mit
command nummer drei soll mit command
nummer drei hoffe ich jetzt mal dass ich
das niveau von diesem video irgendwie
wieder auf ein angemessenes level
bringen und zwar hole ich mir erst mal
wieder den command blog gebe einen level
gebe ich mir auch noch dafür ich den
command ein der von
3333 sito das ist sein name und zwar ist
es einen roboter wir sehen hier schon
diese maschine dort steht allerdings nur
dann klickt of destruction das wollen
wir natürlich nicht sondern wir holen
uns eine qual bzw vier quarz erst dann
holen wir uns ebenfalls eine zielländer
sowie vorhin schon dann holen uns einen
n will und wir holen uns noch einen
namen tag das sind die vier items die
hilfe benötigen
die stars stellen wir hier so vier
nebeneinander hin und packen dort die
zielländer in die mitte ein
jetzt denkt man sich erstmal so was soll
das was passiert es passiert nichts
eigentlich erst mal dafür haben wir
allerdings den entwendeten dort einen
tag rein und nene diesem namen tag passt
genau auf sacrifice was muss man
eingeben sacrifice to the hot rods also
das wird geopfert an die wab götter und
was wird geopfert hat luca was ist das
für eine folge wir holen uns ein kleid
im land eine kuh wird geopfert und jetzt
wollen wir die kuh hier drauf und machen
sacrifice überhaupt gott und ihr seht
schon what has been set zweiten haben
wir ihnen im inventar einige alltags
bekommen 264 group sachen das heißt wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise hierhin lauf
und ich denke mir scheiß ich falle lava
kann ich einfach kurz rechts weg machen
und ich bin wieder hier im ort punkt das
ist quasi alles was dieses dieser
command macht allerdings fragt euch
jetzt bestimmt
kann man sich denn mehrere jobs machen
das können wir ganz einfach testen ich
weiß natürlich nicht antwort aber ich
zeige es euch mal eben und zwar wenn ich
hier einen mord punkten machen
beispielsweise hier wieder eine kuh
opfere
seht ihr schon lopez hier bin said aber
da hinten wird er kaputt gemacht das
heißt wenn ich jetzt hier den gold-award
einsetzt passiert das und wenn ich den
alten gold oberhaupt einsetzte diese
alten items sieht davon hatte komme ich
ebenfalls dorthin
das heißt der andere mit deaktiviert ist
es noch nicht möglich dass man mehrere
web.de hat und mehrere verschiedene
items sondern man hat immer nur ein und
das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut zu den
kann man sich dann zu hause gegen den
keller setzen oder ins haus oder
whatever
und dann geht man quasi mit den items
irib durch weil lava scheiß und ich bin
in der höhle kann
hier rauskommen ich bin wieder zu hause
der freude das war es auch schon mit
dieser episode der minecraft command ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen die ersten
beiden kommen ein bisschen klein
bisschen komisch und haben auch beide
nicht so richtig funktioniert aber ich
hoffe dass euch trotzdem gefallen hat es
getan hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen
wir sehen uns locker auf den video der
ist vielleicht